we talked about compression and
expansion of time when it comes to a
writer meeting their character okay that
that's that's really not with the
writers meeting the characters oh that's
okay but compression and expansion it
has a lot to do with the right your life
autobiographical storytelling the thing
is that we have a tendency by instinct
or whatever to not only tell things in a
chronological order but to tell them
pretty much in real time and we will
tell this happened then this happened
and then this happened
in other words time will feel as we're
telling the story that time is moving
that it's normal case compression and
expansion are two techniques a plane
with time and storytelling one is
compressing time and the other is
expanding it compressing time is I could
move you through I could be telling you
a story and I can move you through a
part of the story much faster much
faster than real time they're very very
very fast and what a couple of things
that happens and I'll try to give you an
example I'm going back to my driving on
the 405 which is a story I just made up
see if I can do it with that and let's
say that that's the story of me having a
tough day and I'm racing I'm on the 4 or
5 racing to get to an appointment or
something like that that's when I see
the yellow car but I want to tell you
what the rest of let's say I want to
tell you what the rest of the rest of
the day has been like up to that point
but it's been a long day and there's
been a lot of things that have happened
so many that if I start listing them all
you go fine fine fine fine fine and
emotionally it won't do much of it you
just get you'll just get a lot of
information like if I told you that my
alarm clock didn't go off what I wanted
to so I got up late and then I had
problems with a shower because I
promised myself I'd fix it and what it
wasn't fixed and I had to hold it with
one hand
and then as I was getting dressed I
spilled something on my favorite shirt
and then I went on and on and on and
then I did this and then as I was going
to get to the appointment I'm going
outside and my neighbor who was really
annoying wanted to talk and she won't
start talking and then I talked to her
for a while and then I'm going on then
trying to get to the car now the car is
fine except I should have washed it and
I should have realized that I'm gonna
meet this person he's got to see my car
and the car was dirty now I could say
all these things are going on but I said
I don't want to even take as much time
as I just took to tell that and also
after a while it goes yeah got it yes
got it got it it's been a bad day got it
got it got it if I compress it I can
tell it very much faster much faster and
still take you on an emotional journey
never say good I'm up and up in the
morning a lot of clock didn't work
didn't work didn't work supposed to be
6:30 got to get there on time take a
shower showers broken always been broken
my fault should've fix it gotta get
there on time where's that there's
this you're beautiful sure put on this
shirt spilled a spill the oatmeal and oh
damn oatmeal gonna change this shirt
don't like this shirt gotta go gotta go
outside there's one that she wants to
talk
can't talk huh gotta go gotta go get in
the car get in and bye Rhonda does she's
still talking bye Ronnie get in the car
should have washed account why didn't I
wash the car this is an important thing
I should have washed the car he's gonna
see the kind of got to get going now
that I just covered the same amount of
time same amount of events but faster
and it becomes more poetic and becomes
more fractured time that's compressing
time now we do this this is built on
what we can do in film with jump cutting
and fast cutting then we've all seen
that when it goes to stop moving moving
through time faster and it puts us in a
different rhythm and that puts us in a
different energy and it creates an
urgency just by the construction of it
of those fast cuts just by the
construction of jumping jumping jumping
jumping through all with all of that and
actually in the piece that I just did I
wove through one phrase that I kept
repeating which you may not recall but
doesn't matter the phrase was gotta get
there on time I've got to get there on
time and I can weave that through and
you may or may not notice it you may not
be that's sort of like a little mantra
that keeps repeating which is really
what the whole compression is about
so that's compression so many times when
we're doing these large stories and
someone says well you have to understand
everything that was happening up until
then I said I got it but we'll have to
compress it it takes a lot of work to do
that it takes a lot of work to explore
that amount of time what really happened
and then to write it and then compress
it the other one which is much more
powerful is the expansion of time the
expansion of time we use when you hit a
point in the story you're telling a
story and it's usually the point the key
moment in the story it's the key moment
if it's a love story it's a key moment
of the first kiss or maybe if it's a
frightening traumatic story it's when
you witnessed something that just
changed your life something maybe
horrible or maybe it was a car accident
or something or something happened in
the story which just riveted you and
it's one of those moments again when you
know something happens and your whole
body seems to change what ripples
through you the embarrassment the fear
the shame the horror that disgusts the
joy whatever it's going it's just
rippling through you then you say okay
how do I tell that and you don't want to
go long and say then I you know and
looked at her looked in her eyes and
then then I'm kissing her and it really
felt great and because that's all and
I'm moving on you go that's it the
expansion of time is what we do is we
stop time we literally stop the story so
if it is the kiss and if it's you're
talking about that moment of that first
kiss and you say I'm looking at her eyes
and her eyes are looking up at me and I
can see the sparkle in her eyes and I
can feel that yes this is the moment I
reach in and I start to kiss her
my lips touch touch her Lipson lips
touching lips warm soft smooth joy oh
tears my tears her tears Oh touchy
touchy wanting needing needing feeling
very and then I can pull myself out of
it now that's an expansion the expansion
of time stops the story and what it does
is it we keep telling the story but we
drop down inside the character to really
explore what's going on
in that moment of time and time is not
moving forward at all or if it is it's
just inching forward maybe a little bit
it's almost like slow motion now and
cinema we use slow motion and things
like to get that same feeling here we do
it because we're not given dealing with
anything visual but doing it just with
words just with words and the main
things that expansion needs it needs a
trigger something to send you into that
in this moment the trigger was the lips
touching is something that visually or
essentially that send you it and it
needs a release something to bring you
out something to snap you out of it so
that you can go back into real time so
that's that's expansion the the release
I didn't put in yet because I was
wanting to explain it first because you
have to plan the release and if so if
I'm in the middle of that kiss I'm
talking about soft touching kissing now
my planned release I'm not gonna bring
myself out of that feeling because it's
such a delicious feeling even if it's a
horrible traumatic feeling you may want
to bring yourself out but you can't
something else has to bring you out of
it
somebody's saying my name would bring me
out of it so if it's touching the lips
touch warm smooth touching lips more one
more mark yeah
something like that Pam so then it
brings me out of it so that's what
expansion expansion allows you to just
immerse yourself and the joy or the
horror or the trauma or the exhilarates
whatever it is of the moment of that key
moment and usually this is what the
whole story is aiming for this moment
anyway and you want to take time with it
that's expansion
you